like even when i was a kid like i
remember remember the first time i'd
ever
gotten anything from this thing called
the tooth fairy now
i'd i'd heard i'd heard about this thing
called the tooth fairy
all my kids right from my friends at
school all your kids
yeah so so not from all my kids from all
my fellow kids at school yeah and they
were saying like oh yeah if you uh
if you if your teeth come out you put it
on your pillow get a bit of money
like someone someone once got like a
pound maybe two pounds
they were like i was like damn that's
that's that's a business opportunity
i just got around stealing people's
teeth yeah i was like damn
so i remember the first time i like had
one of my tooth knocked out i was
so [ __ ] excited i was like my time
has come
finally the tooth fairy wasn't me and
like and like i
and so i go to sleep that day and i what
do i find on my
one on my pillow five [ __ ] pounds
i'm just like holy [ __ ] i'm [ __ ]
rolling in here man
but like also i was a good kid right so
i was like i know i knew my parents
weren't weren't that well off so i was
like
mom you know what i got i got five
pounds but you know what
i don't need it treat yourself mama oh
whoa
i didn't realize at the time i found out
two years later i just gave the five
pounds my mom gave to me
back to my mum and i'm just like mom i
can't believe i've been swindled like
this
she probably thinks she's pretty money
laundering at its
is there any prouder moment as a parent
than if you're kidding me yeah right
that's literally like the whole bible
tales that you hear yeah yeah
i feel like literally good samaritan